[Música]
durante el inicio de las audiencias de
la comisión del congreso de eeuu que
investiga y debaten el asalto al
capitolio del 6 de enero de 2021 el
presidente del comité señaló que el
ataque fue un intento de golpe que puso
en riesgo más de dos siglos y medio de
democracia constitucional
en su primer discurso ante la plenaria
de jefes de estado y gobierno en la
cumbre de las américas el presidente joe
biden resaltó la importancia de defender
la democracia en el continente por su
parte del mandatario argentino alberto
fernández criticó los vetos de
washington a cuba nicaragua y venezuela
miles de argentinos protestaron en las
calles de buenos aires en contra de las
medidas económicas del presidente
alberto fernández los ciudadanos piden
al ejecutivo que garantice el acceso al
trabajo formal y condenan el préstamo
con el fondo monetario internacional-
con el primer desembolsos autorizó el
miércoles
en france 24 estamos de vuelta con las
noticias que marcan las jornadas hoy
valentina torres sánchez y es un gusto
acompañarlos iniciamos en eeuu porque
durante el comienzo de las audiencias de
la comisión del congreso que investiga
el asalto al capitolio nacional en eeuu
el presidente del comité bennie thompson
indicó que según las pesquisas el grupo
ultraderechista proud voice estuvo
detrás del ataque pues horas antes de
los hechos entre 250 y 300 de sus
integrantes acudieron a examinar el
congreso el funcionario señaló que el
asalto fue un intento de golpe que puso
en riesgo 250 años de democracia
constitucional
donaldson estaba en el centro de esta
conspiración y en última instancia
donald trump el presidente de eeuu
incitó a una multitud de enemigos
internos de la constitución a marchar
hacia el capitolio y subvertir la
democracia estadounidense
en la ciudad de los ángeles en eeuu
continúa la novena cumbre de las
américas en su discurso inaugural ante
la plenaria de jefes de estado y
el presidente joe biden abogó por un
continente donde se defienda la
democracia y se proteja el medio
ambiente por su parte el jefe de estado
argentino alberto fernández condenó los
vetos de washington a cuba nicaragua y
venezuela que no fueron invitados al
encuentro
definitivamente hubiésemos querido otra
cumbre de las américas el silencio de
los ausentes nos interpela
para que esto no vuelva a suceder
hirabe quisiera dejar sentado para el
futuro que el hecho de ser país
anfitrión de la cumbre no otorga la
capacidad de imponer el derecho de
admisión sobre los países miembros del
continente el diálogo en la diversidad
es el mejor instrumento para promover la
democracia
y la lucha contra la desigualdad la
multitudinaria caravana migrante que
partidos de tapachula en el sur de
méxico continúa su avance hacia el norte
del país aunque ahora lo hace un poco
fragmentada muchos de los migrantes a
pasaron la noche en la localidad de
huixtla donde algunos de ellos lograron
obtener sus documentos legales para el
tránsito por territorio mexicano
nuestros enviados especiales a chiapas
prepararon el siguiente informe
a huixtla en el sur de méxico donde nos
encontramos ahora llegó la caravana de
miles de migrantes en su mayoría de
venezolanos para resolver por medio de
la presión simbólica de la marcha su
estatus migratorio los migrantes no
tienen otra cosa que este documento que
tanto les han negado la forma múltiple
de emigración con la cual puedan
atravesar méxico rumbo hacia eeuu para
nosotros sentimos que méxico es más
difícil que pasar por el tapón del
darién o sea porque te digo aro ya
cuando llega a méxico llega sin dinero
los alquileres caros no te hacen el
proceso acumulan la gente migración te
quiere sacar los hoteles de la casa
donde puede ver una persecución
almirante los migrantes viajan solos en
familia en estado de embarazo o con
bebés los que no son centroamericanos
tuvieron que atravesar la penosa selva
del darién y muchos trajeron
enfermedades consigo por lo regular en
los niños este se ve muy afectado por
igual los casos de insolación que ellos
llevan o presentan un más que nada luego
de dormir a la intemperie y en el piso
como podemos ver en esta carpa los miles
de migrantes de la cara que recorre el
sur de méxico llegan a estas oficinas de
aduana en huixtla en donde entregan sus
pasaportes aspirando obtener un permiso
de 30 días para moverse por el país
deben armarse de paciencia porque el
proceso es lento y solo cada hora
entregan 20 pasaportes firmados y solo
esperamos que el gobierno cumpla lo que
estaba lo que está prometiendo pero
porque nosotros también hemos cumplido
de la forma de escándalo de la forma
pelea riña ni nada porque la marcha es
pacíficamente pues la caravana según sus
organizadores comenzó con más de 15.000
migrantes pero hoy está fragmentada
muchos de ellos ya recibieron el permiso
migratorio para transitar por méxico y
no planean caminar más debido a la
penuria para sus pies en cambio tomarán
buses que los lleven a la frontera sur
de los eeuu para a través de acuña y
piedras negras atravesar el río grave
los argentinos salieron a las calles de
buenos aires para pedir condiciones de
vida dignas en medio de la gran tasa de
pobreza e inflación del país que ahora
acaba de refinanciar una deuda con el
fondo monetariointernacional
prioridades que estarían por encima del
bienestar de la población según lo
indican sectores de izquierda alva
santana nos amplía
es un descontento que parece no cesar a
medida que los niveles de pobreza y las
condiciones de vida precarias se
mantienen en argentina la población
exige acciones por parte del gobierno
una demanda con la que los argentinos
inundaron las calles de buenos aires
tamacá o lo mismo que marchamos en el
país hace un mes que es por trabajo
genuino contra la pobreza del hambre
no hemos tenido ninguna respuesta de
poder la marcha federal tuvimos
diferentes reuniones con el gobierno la
verdad que fueron todas insatisfactoria
y es que en el país que roza el 60 por
ciento de inflación anual mucha gente
está aguantando hambre como dicen los
argentinos con una tasa de pobreza del
más del 37 por ciento los ciudadanos
exigen una mayor asistencia a los
comedores sociales y a las familias
mientras los precios de los alimentos y
otros productos básicos siguen
aumentando
en alimentos para 400 millones de
personas
47 millones
en una precariedad a la que ahora se le
suma el rechazo al nuevo acuerdo con el
fmi para refinanciar un préstamo que
pidió el gobierno de mauricio macri en
2018 porque la situación social en
argentina se agrava a partir del ajuste
y el acuerdo con el fondo monetario
internacional que el gobierno ha firmado
estableciendo prioridades que no son las
del pueblo argentino según cáritas y la
universidad católica nacional uno de
cada diez argentinos pasa hambre
cotidianamente una situación
insostenible para muchos en otras
noticias los rebeldes separatistas en el
este de ucrania condenaron a muerte a
tres combatientes extranjeros que
luchaban para el ejército ucraniano se
trata de dos ciudadanos británicos y uno
marroquí anteriormente se habían
declarado culpables de los cargos que se
les imputaban entre los que figuran
terrorismo comisión de un delito como
parte de un grupo delictivo y toma del
poder por la fuerza los hombres tienen
un mes para apelar la sentencia que debe
ser aceptada la pena podría variar desde
cadena perpetua o veinte años de prisión
un tribunal del este de ucrania
controlado por rusia ha condenado a
muerte a dos británicos y a un ciudadano
marroquí tras un proceso de tres días de
duración fueron capturados mientras
luchaban para el ejército ucraniano en
mariupol
y esperaba que la sentencia fuera mucho
más justa y teniendo en cuenta que ayude
a la investigación y también porque me
entregué a la república popular de
donets los dos británicos se entregaron
a las fuerzas prorrusas en la ciudad
portuaria de mariupol en abril mientras
que el ciudadano marroquí se rindió en
la ciudad oriental de bolt no baja en
marzo cada uno de ellos se declaró
culpable en diferentes tribunales de la
república popular de danielle los
separatistas les acusan de ser
mercenarios a pesar de que afirman haber
luchado junto a los militares ucranianos
moscú ha argumentado que los
considerados mercenarios extranjeros que
luchan por ucrania no son combatientes
regulares y por lo tanto no tienen
derecho a las protecciones concedidas a
los prisioneros de guerra una afirmación
muy discutida por los funcionarios
ucranianos y británicos
existentes
se trata de dos ciudadanos británicos y
han estado sirviendo en las fuerzas
armadas ucranianas mucho antes de la
invasión ilegal de ucrania por el
régimen de putin fueron capturados por
las fuerzas armadas rusas cerca de
mariupol y deben ser tratados de acuerdo
con la convención qué es el derecho
internacional como prisioneros de guerra
no lo es
un funcionario pro ruso de tony a es que
dijo que se les impuso la pena de muerte
como una forma excepcional de justicia
son los primeros combatientes
extranjeros condenados por los
separatistas ucranianos apoyados por
rusia y tienen un mes para apelar la
sentencia
llegamos así al final del informativo
pero los invitamos a ampliar todo
nuestro contenido y repetir este otros
programas en la web france24 puntocom
les agradecemos acompañarnos en esta
jornada volvemos en breve con más
noticias
[Música]